so you know you've done a lot of
interesting things already through your
career and and obviously Shadows is huge
but if someone has never seen anything
you've done before what do you actually
want them watching first and why
oh that's a good question
um you know I I try to like pride myself
in doing different roles that are
different from each other
um something to start off with would
probably I mean Shadows you can't go
wrong with you know uh for animation
obviously uh Puss in Boots would be
great because those are two different
characters uh yeah it depends it depends
what your demo is are you into comedy
are you into more of a drama are you
into more animation so it would depend
but I would definitely have a good menu
for you and we have a starter a main
course and a dessert when they contacted
you about the Puss in Boots sequel was
it sort of like did you even ask what
the character was were you like wait you
want me to voice a character in The Puss
in Boots sequel where do I sign well no
they asked me to audition first it
wasn't an offer and they asked me what
do you like to audition and I and I
thought that exactly was like you want
me to audition it would be an honor you
know so the audition alone I thought you
know I'm not gonna get it you know you
always think don't you know you hope for
the best but just do your best work and
put it forward but never have this like
you know entitlement of like it's mine
and so I auditioned hoping for the best
and then they said they wanted another
Zoom with the director and everyone was
like okay and then they told me I got it
and I just remember thinking oh my gosh
I'm what like this is happening and even
then I still didn't believe it through
the recording session because you never
know because Hollywood's so fickle
something could change automatically so
it was until really recently that I was
like I'm in this movie I am in it right
like I'm doing it and you have a big
part
if I'm being honest
um I I didn't know what I was expecting
with the puss in Booth sequel but it's
real good like way better than I
expected and like I'm recommending it to
everyone what was your reaction watching
the finished film and seeing the
animation and the story and seeing it
all come together I mean I I think it's
fantastic I just I didn't expect the
animation to be so you know Advanced I
was expecting you know because we're so
used to animation what it's been for the
last decade uh but this new version of
what we're going towards in the future
was just mind-blowing I just remember
seeing it and I I knew what the script
was because we had recorded it and could
only imagine what it would be and I know
what puss looks like and I know what you
know uh kitty soft paws looks like but
to put them all together in this this
world and the adventure they go on just
like the smallest detail of twinkling
blue lights in the dark Forest that just
like are mesmerizing it's a haunted you
know scary Forest they're going into but
yet it looks so beautiful that you're
like I you know what I take the risk I
go in there it's just beautiful it's it
was stunning what do you actually think
would surprise people to learn about the
recording process that maybe they don't
realize well it seems people think oh
you went in there you did it in one day
you know and just like it's done and
it's like no it's a process like you go
in and you figure out who the voice is
and you discover it and then you get
directed our director was amazing and
and the the way the film came out it
looks like we were all in the same room
performing in front of each other and in
reality we're all different times those
different you know countries even
because we all live around the world and
working around the world that it was the
director who kind of railed that in to
make it look so cohesive and linear to
the story that it looks like yeah we
went on this adventure all together in
the same room uh and it's it's hard work
it's a lot of hard work for for
animation people don't know that well
the other thing I've spoken to a lot of
people that do voice over and uh they Dr
they love doing it they've dread the
efforts where you have to record the
grunts and the whatever those kinds of
sounds are so did you you have to do a
lot of efforts and what are your
thoughts on those I did especially when
he's trying to mimic the you know the
look for the the cats when he's like
being adorable and cute and he can't do
it quite yet because he's already an
octave higher than my voice so the
straining had to go even higher than
that so it was like the I remember doing
that scene I think we have footage of it
where it's just me doing and going
and just going reaching for and reaching
for and that was just really like every
ounce of my body just engaged uh it's a
lot of work it's a lot it's a workout
yeah I I uh I think people don't realize
when you leave that the voiceover room
your voice is like don't talk ever again
yeah I'm taking the vocal rest yeah
exactly that you go home you sleep like
a baby and you feel it because it's the
only muscle that you were really kind of
just completely working out that day uh
full out any the only instrument you can
rely on to tell the story as opposed to
your whole body when did you actually
realize uh what we do in the shadows was
like taking off if you know what I mean
I really didn't know what we were doing
um you know with the fans and whatnot I
knew that we had fans who adored us and
did fan work and it was amazing we have
to remember that we Shot season uh three
and four during a pandemic and so season
one was like a a critical darling that
everyone knew about and if you were knew
about it you were in the know and so it
was like you were cool to know about it
because it was like an independent thing
and then season two got more accolades
and more attention and by season three
and four we shot those Seasons under
pandemic so we don't really get to go
out and about and it's not until
recently that like walking down the
street you know went out to dinner in
New York last night walking out the door
and this girl stops in her tracks and
excuse me and then it's like you forget
that people recognize you because of
this program uh because we lived in a
bubble for the last you know hibernation
of like two and a half years so it's now
only now that we're coming out of that
bubble and it's like you're living your
regular life that you lived you know
beforehand but you forget oh that's
right people are going to recognize
because they watch the show so that's
when I start realizing more and more
people stop you on the street
so I'm really looking forward to the
Blue Beetle movie which I know you have
a role in what was your reaction because
originally it was going to go HBO Max
and now it's going in theaters so what
was your reaction when you heard hey
this movie's going into theaters I think
it deserves to be in theaters I think
that is the best choice
um the script is amazing uh Anka the
director has such a vision for it and
I'm so proud to be a part of it it's an
all Latino cast and it's never been done
and uh the first you know Latino
superhero uh that's Blue Beetle himself
is just gonna be you know mind breaking
it's gonna be revolutionized the way
that kids are going to see themselves
represented on television on screen uh
you know in film it and in the time has
come that we need to like show kids that
they are valued they are included in the
table and they are welcome to be part of
this field so I'm really excited to be a
part of that have to ask you uh who do
you play the film what can you tease
about your role uh well they haven't
announced who I played in the film and I
can't announce it yet uh but I will tell
you that it is a crucial person to the
overall story
that's a very good politician answer and
I just say thank you so much I'm so
happy for your success thank you uh and
have a fantastic day thank you so much
thanks everyone at Collider